buenas noches las mujeres exigen
justicia para las víctimas de violencia
sexual y feminicidio también una nueva
constitución que prioriza la igualdad de
género el respeto a los derechos humanos
de todas las mujeres también pide acceso
mixto a la política libre de acoso ellas
se están demandando entre otras cosas
participación y de que sea una educación
sexual integral para que nadie padezca
embarazos ni maternidad de forzadas
asimismo piden que se haya una reforma
policial para que las mujeres no sufran
el acoso sexual por parte de algunos
policías durante las jornadas de
protesta podemos decir que la violencia
contra la mujer se ha convertido en perú
como una nueva pandemia en la defensoría
del pueblo ha detallado que en lo que va
de enero a octubre de este año
4500 mujeres niñas y adolescentes han
sido registradas como desaparecidas en
paralelo el ministerio de la mujer y
poblaciones vulnerables ha señalado que
a la fecha se han registrado 101
feminicidios 234 tentativas de
feminicidios y 6 mil 893 casos de
violencia sexual es por eso que
diferentes organizaciones les piden a
las autoridades peruanas medidas
urgentes de solución con justicia y
equidad